[Music]
not a good luck I'm [ __ ] starving
thank you
and the food just literally as we're
coming back on the other food she's got
put down Jim is turning into Joe Pesci
I'm gonna split them as Snickers I'm
just really hungry and like you know
usually you eat around 9:00 and this
[ __ ] place whatever their delivery
service is dink
maybe I luck Anthony you're gonna take
this on yourself Yeah right we just go
somewhere else that's all like like or
just go down there or I'll pay for
summer I don't care I'll spend the
money's I don't I don't need them to
expense it I'll pay it I just want to
eat at nine o'clock because like you get
up at seven and it was two hours in
check my or even if Jim's paying for
tech my order on with Jim's hey [ __ ]
[ __ ] you just start aside anyway you
know just have a sighs school turkey
bacon just a little protein to get over
that eggs no I don't need a turkey bacon
rules too man oh my god you know what
you put it on some toast shits or some
tomato and lettuce on there get a full
meal
you know you animate oh and lettuce huh
yeah yeah no I just I just want a little
bit of protein to keep hood to keep the
wheels in motion and that's all I would
have Elsie and so long there's a best
there the best of all sandwiches
well Mayo got a turkey club though you
just had turkey and you got into even a
little something more you know I just
never thought about that way what's your
favorite food of all time yeah it's a
great question so what you're saying is
that death row food you know this is
something that the that chefs talk about
all the time what would you have on
death row I'm sure is something that my
mom made for me you know I mean things
like I would go back to a comfort food
that she admit like what maybe fried
chicken mashed potatoes goulash yeah
because we're from Russia so that was
always you know back then but isn't it
funny but people consider comfort food
is it like like people from China if
they get nervous to have rice and
vegetables a guy had a bad day today I'm
gonna race about that would be a
nightmare for us yeah you know we want
something normally like Italian
something big and car being thick
but I think would be along those lines I
don't think it would it be from a
restaurant I feel like my my mom cooks
all the time she's a very good cook
jo seho mom you know your dad made
enough money where he didn't have to
force her to leave the child alone right
right why would you take out a couple
loans or something but yeah I would
probably get a [ __ ] ton of food from
Taco Bell really whole bunch of chalupas
with no sour cream and a whole bunch of
quesadillas with no sauce
you don't want real Mexican food you'd
rather go to Taco Bell much rather try
no sauce in I don't like this all yeah
it's a little sauce on there it gives
you a kick though let me get right let
me just a little salsa Luis never had
somebody do this like just let me let me
just put this on there you're gonna love
it
just I'll just try yeah it's really
[ __ ] hot why would I want to eat
something that was so hot it was
uncomfortable from my mouth it burnt
everything yes or in your mouth are you
feeding it so why would I want to eat it
yeah yeah
what would your would your death-row
meal be I don't know
fried chicken sounds good Iida but if
the pieces that give you a party [ __ ] no
you get your any pieces you want like my
favorite little spots Barros right down
the road that's nice
really I mean my perfect death-row meal
and this would be just probably three
lines of coke and a little bit [ __ ]
heroin just to take the edge off just
enough to give you that huh right yeah
you don't want to not out you know I
mean there's not too much heroin but a
nice speedball the kind Belushi did and
maybe OD before you even get down the
[ __ ] hall take it one last [ __ ] you
yeah my turn
you don't want to coke though the last
thing you needed to be jittery and wide
awake for that [ __ ] you're very tired
and go I want some coconut and a [ __ ]
phone just to call some people I haven't
talked to a yeah that's a they say that
that lethal injection like you may or
may not like you did some issue but like
what if you know it's happening right
they don't know I mean how can they know
for sure it doesn't hurt if everybody's
dead that it's ever happened to he's
going to do to kill you and I really
this sounds barbaric but it's fast put
your head on a piece of metal and have a
giant metal press slam down on it and in
a nanosecond you're dead what did you
shoot you why would they go to that
because that's faster and an instant
shoot you in there you
but across your arm your head crushed no
but if I would do that to be suffocated
close your eyes I'm just good daughter I
can't even think of something why
shouldn't it yeah exactly
what would your death row so after you
have your coke and heroin yeah for your
last meal how are you going out for me
if they gave you the choices they cut
off my [ __ ] and balls and let me just
bleed out because you're a [ __ ]
champion I think I like kicking around
and screaming yeah afterwards yeah well
your feeling man
you know what dig it we go to general I
mean if I was wanted in jail it was
Jimmy's death row I just have Anthony
order food and actually he'll starve to
death
Anthony come on dude you're [ __ ]
representing okay what happened there
was a [ __ ] failure um I do I do go
for this crushing the head you like that
yes cuz I've never heard of it before it
does any never been a country not let's
crush the head no it's fast yeah but
what's wrong with just like shooting a
gun what's wrong with just either using
a shotgun to blow his head off I miss it
may miss an even decapitation I've seen
video and I saw recently if a guy whose
head got cut off right and they held the
head up and it looked up at the person
I've heard about that you do survive it
I've seen it like again it's very fast
but you can see the AH it's chilling
when you see the eyes look up you've got
that one split-second of like they say
30 seconds no way I've heard 30 second I
even heard one guy was talking about
telling you a story about a medical
examiner I guess it was an old tale
recounted or we could but the the guy's
head got off in a guillotine and he said
the guy grimaced when they touched the
spinal column of the head like Kristen
pain my neck hurts yeah and a cop told
the story but his friends head getting
cut off in the accident and he said he
could see the expression on his friend's
face change from like horror to pain or
something you know or just finally like
just letting go yeah are you positive
you're claustrophobic you know you don't
like it you don't might elevate herself
no no but I I wouldn't want to be like
bury disease being buried alive your
greatest fear yeah I'm saying yeah yeah
do you see that Ryan Reynolds movie
because I'm not once and I mean I so bad
it's as bad as you think it is is what I
don't want
movies like that and I don't watch
movies where anything bad happens to a
kid right and to be honest even their
dog I don't like when it darlings
[ __ ] killed but any of these things
of Dave we've captured your child and
you got 20 foot now fall you know you
take it no wow dude take it tell me do
they get the kid back they do okay they
do maybe I'll watch the end of it we're
not watching the early part no but he's
got a certain set of skills you guys see
all his skill don't Anya don't ruin it
for me now I mean you already told me
gotta get back I can sky my hair with
its jet like a tire painter you know who
I think is the best all the death
penalty's those Muslims where you just
thrown enough rocks of someone to say
dad you don't like this is 200 [ __ ]
rocks finally kill like I've been hit
with a rock before it hurts but I didn't
think I could die from this
yeah nowhere near dad yeah oh yeah these
things where they throw you off a roof
that's a big one to two gays no roof I
haven't seen this other documentary when
people jumped off the Golden Gate Bridge
again Roger yeah and they all said on
the way down [ __ ] what did I do
those survivors the survivors said that
they regretted it on the way down I'll
go now you're regretting yeah that's
what I think that's that a that bridge
documented the bridge I'm sorry yes same
for the Golden Gate Bridge thing yeah
now the chester bennington way that he
went out the other day with a belt right
it's weird how you just hear something
like that and it kind of puts it in the
[ __ ] zeitgeist where people are like
yeah who knows who's gonna end up killed
himself I don't think he'd probably have
a thought when he was younger all
probably end up killing myself one day
where do you get to that point who knows
what he might have been a lifelong
depression depressed person yeah you
know like he probably struggle with it
for a long time he had probably gone
I've said this about Chris Cornell he
probably gone through that scenario so
many times to be thinking about it I'm
starting it he probably put it around
his neck a hundred times and never just
done it he probably felt the club what
the pressure would feel like he applied
held the belt up just to see how does
this feel to be choked guaranteed that
he did not that was not his first time
but why don't you just start there's
some conspiracy theories now going on
these are killed
yeah because killing the guy from
Lincoln Park was a bacon there's
anything there saying if you read this
here it's it's there's some weird stuff
because Chester was Chris Cornell's
Godfather to one of his kids and then uh
Chester died on Chris Cornell's birthday
so they're saying that there's some
weird ties going on so what does that
have to do it since that was just final
piece of oppression if you read the
article here I've seen this a couple
times on the internet but they were
covering up a pedophile ring
everything is pedophile pedophile rings
considers the virus it's always a
pedophile thing it was a big pedophile
ring just delete what about becoming a
what about this becoming why don't you
just do drugs until you die here I'm a
judge away rock stars used to be right
to drugs do drugs do drugs and then die
but then he had Robin Williams who did
like a ton of drugs in the 80s and then
he didn't die and then he used the belt
at the end yeah you know weird that's
three celebrities now who belted it out
not even [ __ ] gun to that well I
think III wouldn't be surprised if the
Chris Cornell thing was implanted in the
Chester's head and so maybe he was like
maybe even after Chris Cornell did it
that's when he started doing what you
said Jim where he's like let me see oh
that's how he did it
let me see what this feels like you
don't need any special feeling you got
something you think I'm on your own it's
not something if it's the same as your
everybody yeah of course I've dealt
around the neck that's [ __ ] [ __ ]
kill yourself what I want oh that's not
that's not a new thought I about yeah
when I was a kid like 9th to 10th grade
a kid in my school hung themselves like
from a [ __ ] tire swing like they went
like this place in the woods where
everybody used to go and swing up this
thing he'd [ __ ] cut it new stuff and
died there was like I go to the funeral
what was the wake that'd be like eight
hundred [ __ ] kids all lined up and I
met I got a little jealous I'm like
because of all the attention yeah me
like look at all the attention I wonder
how many people would have you know like
maybe there's a scenario where you can
fake something no you can get that nice
rather just be laying there have a
girl's crying over me like people crying
for him
over his dead body I'm like oh Jesus
Christ he's really making things happen
but then I didn't want everybody think I
was ripping them off at the time
probably what everything they all we
know it take is remember when I went at
reistad you got all that attention and
everybody started thinking I wonder how
many I'm wondering Stone would pick it
up if I died right what I mean yeah all
of a sudden you know all those
publications decided patrice was finally
yeah he was reciting itis yeah right
nobody mentioned it before but makes you
want to kind of just make sure that you
have leaving some stuff like here take a
listen to this after I think we're
really gonna get like a cat oh yeah yeah
you get a kick out a lot of good stuff
unreleased stuff
yeah a lot of unreleased stuff you
should do shows just engraving
every time yes Joe yet do it do a show
after your show and just record it and
just have a whole bunch of show it that
way your radio show could just continue
on or if you committed suicide and
you're [ __ ] taping it everybody's
going to want to [ __ ] and you know you
just do you know some really funny stuff
for the first hour and a half and then
BAM you're done right right that's a
great idea especially a podcast you do a
whole bunch yeah in advance if you know
you're going to die just maybe one take
three what would be great is you like if
the three of us were doing one at a time
we die you know I mean so it's like okay
I got to go now guys and boom I shoot
myself in the head you've never [ __ ] you
know I didn't see that coming you're
laughing you're [ __ ] around
everyone's thinking oh my god they're
not doing anything help bullying them
stand kills himself right true and I
just celebrate yet Jim Darwin goes on
ten presidents [ __ ] gigs of Montreal
yeah let everybody know he's gonna be at
the Borgata and then boom I mention shot
the door [ __ ] leave [ __ ] chipton
Montreal is that going to work though um
I think so
and then he's doing a gig no chip not
gonna get Montreal all he's doing a live
gig in New York he's number level
different length I haven't announced
that all of the chip live show is
September 11th to the Village
Underground ticket information will be
given out next week on the chip podcast
September 11th that noted the date on
Paris
yeah Russia
I already have the dates available with
a fifth of the 11th and the day after
Labor Day is a bad day to do AG 11th is
not a September 11th is an OK day at
this point yeah I just pointed look I
consider this chip September 11th show
our September 11th yeah I mean this is
our 911 for our generation right the
guys that were too young to remember
what happened yet trip should call it
the new 911 hmm right just something
that everybody's going to remember where
is it going to be at by the way Village
Underground tickets are not on sale till
next week though Wow
be exciting did you hear it speaking of
exciting and you guys watch the big race
last night I'm a part of it I think no
white people we're back getting great
again no I meant ways south vs. shark no
no I didn't even know this was on
everything comes on Sunday nights too
much for me right no I had anxiety yeah
I can't watch that's just too
humiliating for Michael Phelps well it
was had to shark yeah sharks humiliated
people people were people were furious
you know Shark Week has become a bit of
a parody of itself no one cares about it
anymore
I'm saving shark we people care about it
Shark Week anyway it wasn't a lane for
real no that's not that's that was a
fake photo people got pissed because
they had Phelps swimming in shark water
but then they added a shark with CGI
next to him so they already had the time
the shark had raced so Michael Phelps
was racing a CGI shark and there have
been all this promotion oh there were
treats everywhere they've been all this
promotion that Michael Phelps versus a
shark and then everybody was tweeting
because they expected you put a shark in
a pool and it stays in its claim and you
get to see Michael Phelps and a shark
it's not this [ __ ]
how [ __ ] what is it discovery stinks
now I ads Hierophant used to be really
good and they have just turned into this
but they did it with the guy getting
eaten by the snake swallowed whole yup
they didn't remember do any stunts too
[ __ ] awful like a year or two ago for
Shark Week they did the fake real
documentary about how they had found
mermaids oh yeah
trying to get people into thinking that
they now just hit on me zombie are means
they did something on that yeah but they
made it like it was real it's a quick
fate it's a quick way that we've counted
the shark
it must be CGI the circus did Elaine
[ __ ] turn him went to the end of the
pool that thing we dive down and kick
off again yeah the shark did win though
by seconds but it won seconds is a lot
and they said it circulated shark at the
end yeah they say highly elated the
whole time enough simulated Wow while it
was it's not even a real Phelps while it
was happening yeah yes while they were
advertising it no and he's got a
mermaid's tail some said a mermaid's
tail they did they put him in and they
were and they tried to kiss it I mean
people on Twitter are going crazy they
got all theirs tweets everywhere about a
you know being upset that there was no
real shark so they tried to do damage
control and they said but Phelps was
swimming in shark-infested water so
there was real danger they said we had
divers that were there watching Michael
felt you want him to Rachel shark put
him in the water
open the cage let the shark chase him
right let's see if he's quicker than her
sure put some Chum on his [ __ ] feet
yeah give him a head start
shark beat him by two seconds you're
right that is a gigantic that's huge
yeah I guess he's not that good after
all no he sucks can you imagine it like
winning all those gold medals you're
supposed to be the pride of your country
and the only thing that's left after the
Olympics is raising a fake shark that
you humiliated you know they had Jesse
Owens race the [ __ ] horse right in
the 40s or something really yeah I'm
[ __ ] gimmick he really raised a horse
yeah but but he did a hundred yards in
the horse that [ __ ] like five hundred
yards or something always it just I
didn't know that and who won I did he do
with a horse did he could we see one you
must know if Jesse Owens beat a horse
alone if he ran a hundred yards faster
the horse ran five hundred yeah well
they didn't have the technology for CGI
horses yet no too bad yeah cuz otherwise
that kind of look really cool
yeah and then afterwards and then the
sense they call Jesse had to take a piss
and they wouldn't let him use his
restroom
he has
down who was stall and pee there wow
this was years ago automatic terrible
that was the 80s I mean the old timers
you know that I love la song you just
come out Randy no no Darius is Jesse
racing his father question yes he won by
engine you won by inches who did this
Jesse Owen the music is so bad I mean
the whole exercise is a terrible why is
the horse running around the [ __ ]
thing it's so humid what do you mean
he's racing nobody's ranch cut across
look how happy is that is so
dehumanizing let's see if you're faster
than this animal now it's also
dehumanizing to run in front of Hitler
you know that no one ever brings that up
yeah he beat Hitler in a [ __ ] race
see a handshake didn't Hitler walk away
yeah Hitler
they said plug in rubbed his balls and
then [ __ ] but yeah and he goes like
this here shake my ball my [ __ ] ball
sweat getting the stink finger yeah yeah
your honor why is my fingers smell like
Hitler's [ __ ] now yeah that was the
first indication that Hitler was rude
Hitler was not [ __ ] nice no one ever
brings that up yeah Hitler was being a
lot of people you got in polite yes I'll
tell you this though
devil's advocate he put together a hell
of an opening ceremony at the Olympics
yeah that is true a lot of that pomp and
circumstance that we celebrate today
would not have been around had it not
been for Hitler no one is saying that
Hitler had no good qualities I'm just
saying he wasn't him he was a rude
Versailles weekend now they're saying
didn't they say they had a tiny [ __ ]
Hulk decked oh yeah then he had this
little [ __ ] fishhook of a dick little
micro penis they think that Adam and it
was [ __ ] curved up and around again
and he said that had him pissed off yeah
I I I think though that sometimes I
think I will see it over the years every
few years the newspapers are allowed to
just print a terrible story about Hitler
having a small penis yeah yeah who's
going to correct them who's going to say
like Wow is the Hitler family but dang
paper using a zig was normal size
average they're just trying to milli
eight
I'm not going to take a great man
they're just trying to humiliate you
know a [ __ ] guy who's hateable I read
and I read to several places his [ __ ]
ball was so small not a little hole in
it like a cheerio the kids in the school
would go um cheerio at balls but it was
like the German version of that of
cheerio ball tire balls it sure is
better little tires yeah
and then ours Tim went a little bit
holes in him he went to summer camp and
they forced them put his balls in this
little thing of milk yeah I like
breakfast cereal right you know he was
like one [ __ ] and I think was Jewish
kids who did it it was one [ __ ] day
I heard they would call them honey nuts
cheerio that's [ __ ] because nuts you
know he said I like you said in German
yeah in German in German in the native
language there but also the other thing
about [ __ ] Hitler that no one brings
up is that it was a lovely painter my
wife Haner not quite good enough to go
profession that's what [ __ ] him up if
somebody if I could go back in time and
by Hitler's paintings perhaps none of
this would have happened
yeah that is true if his if his easy
really was a frustrated artist I mean
that's what happened to Charles Manson
he wanted my rock star
Charles Manson wanted yeah yeah when I
had a toddler he has much good garbage
dump was the big head he has name of the
songs right if you could go back in time
and kill anybody who would it be
my agent last September yeah it's still
not too late you can still
what about feel that's a real tough one
one person one you only get to kill one
you only get to do it one time because I
would love to go back in time and kill
Lincoln right before John Wilkes Booth
got there just to see the expression on
his face it was just like what the [ __ ]
this right yeah right and I'd be like
this little [ __ ] late Ringo and I'd
be gone again
maybe like Ringo what's the [ __ ] said
even mean I then he'd still have to
escape so you probably do the same thing
you'd get away with it what do you just
say a guy shot him and then disappeared
back into the future provided
got a Hitler painting right there the
rug on the right not that one that one
that's pretty good
yeah it's nice I mean I'd [ __ ] hang
that over my couch today well yeah but
that's because you failed yeah yeah are
they yeah cool Tim oh yeah there's a
place down at the mall original Hitler
yeah yeah I was going to get one there
wasn't enough space I get something big
over my couch right you know then we
having small ones yeah they sold for
half a million dollars yeah would you I
mean I think also be thrilling to go
back in time and kill Sarah Connor long
before her son was born ha yeah I
probably uh I probably killed a Night
Stalker Richard Ramirez was a one-guy
yeah he just seemed like he had such an
ego about him you know I don't like him
he's killing random people he's telling
old ladies he just thinks that oh so
you're like focus [ __ ] yeah I just
feel like none of the rules apply to VA
they said he only ate junk food so his
breath stank and his teeth were rotting
out so realize mean to say though you
know it's like Hitler's balls with it
with the cheerio balls yeah honey nuts
if I was a serial killer I'd always take
a prize for my victim as always and I wa
I would leave a calling card oh wow I
already know my oh you're calling hobby
I would probably take off a pinky toe
with me I'd be the pinky toe killer Wow
and then back at my lair I'd have a lair
just be a jar of [ __ ] pinky toast now
would you at all worried about the fact
that if anybody were to get in your lair
the jar of pinky toes would be a dead
giveaway that wouldn't even Donald may
be totally out whether they would smell
yeah why would you yeah tight right yeah
if we don't put new chosen and I would
have what do you put in there like
formaldehyde and formaldehyde had that
like Barbasol stuff that blue stuff that
you put the combs in I don't want to get
confused and upcoming my hair with a
pinky toe aspect and I mean because
that's happened to me before
yeah and then I wait I cut stuff out of
the newspaper make messages out of it
send it to the FBI
oh that's smart but they know who it is
doctor so few people buy newspapers
pants and it be able to now it's our
neighborhood but I really say like looks
like I've been towing the line lately so
you know I mean like I've been a lot of
toes stuff little buns yeah would you
send it to newspaper editors
yeah I'd pick out a guy in
poor probably day a blogger oh yeah your
generation I sent it to a blogger yeah
see what they had to do but the HuffPo
now yeah
and just when use the word like put I'm
going to kill someone else in town but
then capitalize with tio W or the M is
low case that cuz then they make them
figure out Megan work for it you know oh
it's a signal yeah yeah we know they
like it I guess you didn't know that you
know some of the stuff wouldn't be dead
on where will I be next yeah oh I don't
tell ya perhaps Towson Maryland oh the
thing is got it you've got to give them
something yes you know we're just gonna
leave a body buying you know the irony
to it what your job would be how they
finally cash your house up be a tow
truck sure that would be the [ __ ]
best alright show it I shall tow than a
truck and I just right imagine what I do
for there's anybody need to be towed I'm
the [ __ ] guy to call get it yeah
you're not worried about the sleuths
that would be you know here's what would
happen is the police wouldn't know how
to deal with you it'd be one journalist
who used to be like a comic strip artist
but we just wanted a shot at the
newspaper that would just be pining away
at all your clues you know the one that
would find you by the way I don't know
why I love that movie but I do
don't [ __ ] it's Lamoni but it's react I
watch it all the time nothing happens in
the movie nothing and it's comforting
somehow three hours long yeah and I'm
with you I will watch it anytime I have
it like like yeah I love that movie and
you're right
nothing happened not even happen he
doesn't even get like the the Mark
Ruffalo character doesn't even get that
crazy or Manica I don't remember that I
saw it it's the same guy who made seven
and it's not a true story though it's
how about the Zodiac killer
you know this yeah it is no that's why
nothing happens because in real life
they never solve those kind of crimes
yeah people just die of old age yeah
because you can't get somebody who is it
like trying to kill their brother-in-law
you know there's no motive you know how
easy would be just if you want to kill
someone and then just you know that's it
that's why get Richard Ramirez
real early he was a bad guy no motives
you know one of the people he killed the
old lady I think he had killed her
husband and she had a shotgun into the
bed she pulls the shotgun out and she
pointed at him and he stops and she
pulls the trigger and it goes click
because their grandchildren had been
over so her husband unloaded the gun so
he beat her to death with a pile lamp or
something it would be better just a
legal loaded gun around the ground
children or just pointed and don't shoot
you say get out yeah get out or I'll
kill you no one's gonna say go ahead
pull the trigger
she didn't realize it wasn't loaded yeah
she wanted to shoot if I was limited
what a fan huh what a sound click oh
shoot yeah I'd be I doubt nerds I try it
again hoping the second one is a bullet
hold on a second you put in
he's down yet what even the choker right
that was his logic bludgeon
yeah I don't either rapist I don't
remember you would rape he was
postmortem
I think pre-mortem old he we killed old
ladies and he beat these two old a
dinner with a lamp I think Travis Peck
yeah because I'm have to kill the young
forgotten attractive he might have
killed some younger people to yeah but
he did a disgusting teeth yeah he'd
sneak into people's houses and just kind
of hang out he would always tuck his uh
pants into his socks yup - so he didn't
get them caught nerd another that's a
[ __ ] nerd boy